what happened tonight we had a lot of
fun that's what happened which I loved
and I feel like it shows yeah we were
mechanics then we had a lot of fun yeah
we put in work and we got soaked
[Music]
who do you think did the shower portion
better you guys or Gleb and that I love
and I'll crush that performance didn't
bring a smile to your face like you're
not a happy person smile to my face um
in theme with the name of the song I'm
too sexy what is the sexiest thing that
Kendall does when she gets mad she's
sexy follow that face this summer right
of them and turns me on what about you
and Val what's the sexiest thing he does
he makes me laugh a lot and I think
that's super sexy I think a man with a
sense of humor is jordyn seen these two
so in love with their significant others
are you looking right now to find maybe
what they have I mean absolutely that's
how you end up on the show you know in
bachelor nation as you're looking for
love and if love is lost you continue to
keep looking you recover and you move on
and we'll see there's someone out there
for me my girls out there so I don't
wanna put you on the spot but anything
that you want to say any comments that
you have hopeful in relation to anything
that happened today no I've already put
that behind me so and you would have
killed it tonight you only practice for
two days and he never he doesn't a lot
of dance so Jenna had a very hard task
on her she did a good job the MVP like
they said yeah um Disney Week is next
week what do you guys have in store a
lot of happiness a lot of happiness
Disney is always fun and it should just
feel childish and playful and exciting
so we're gonna bring your channeling
Walt Disney and I don't know I don't
think we're allowed to say Bobby and
Charlotte old oh yeah I don't know I
don't know I don't want to get makeup
well oh we're making about became any
are my favorite yeah king in the Queen
shocking elimination tonight though with
Tinashe and Brandon how surprised were
you guys she's amazing she gets tense
she's probably the best dancer here you
know either the celebs and so it's hard
though you know it comes down to votes
at the end of the day and so I'm super
grateful that we got stick around
another week and we're just gonna keep
pushing I've seen Tinashe perform at a
concert she sings she dances while she's
singing she's very talented
a little surprising but last question
it's called Dancing with the Stars any
stars that you are crushing on right now
I need celebs that we can try and set
you up with I'm speechless
Carla Johansson throw something on her
Britney Spears I mean Kate Upton's
pregnant so or she said she just had a
baby so I mean it's a lot of luck
[Music]